wow wow you look very slick tonight
thanks a lot man thank you
wow thank you that's like an elvis vest
that's very nice that's cool thank you
very much
i appreciate it yeah yeah right so
you're in the parade today that's gotta
be exciting i woke up at five of six
this morning and uh went out there into
that freezing cold it was freezing today
yeah and
i was out there last night and it was
like 20 degrees i know and we were up on
this float this like humongous float it
was absolutely huge
and uh and it was even worse up up there
so we were like my face was like numb
how long were you on the float actually
you ride yeah you ride it it takes about
an hour and
45 minutes you know even though you're
only on camera about you know three
seconds
so you know is there a bathroom on the
float or so you have to get off the
whole bedroom and everything down you
can go down below and yeah you're just
sitting in this like
wood chamber and it's freezing cold
there's nothing up there no sounds like
fun
it does we actually have a clip of you
uh on the floor what was the theme of
the float
i was i was the under the sea under the
sea
all right let's take from the little
more you're a little more that one yeah
let's take a look okay okay
[Music]
[Applause]
there you are i see you there with are
those your two brothers yes matthew and
andrew yes all right and you're like
you're coaching them you're saying to
one of them
very audibly okay now you sing actually
andrew because andrew was like freezing
cold we were literally we had to sit on
andrew for about 10 blocks because
andrew is it was so cold so
he was just kind of numb and i was kind
of trying to get him to do it because he
was like singing you know what i wanted
right
i was trying to get him to do certain
things because i watched that and i
watched these people lip syncing to
these very complex numbers
right and you know they're all out in
the middle of the street in new york and
the song is being played
you can barely hear it how do you do it
you know you just have to uh they uh
send you a
tape you know and fortunately i don't
lip sync ever except you know when you
do things like this because
uh it's just not cool but um you know i
was like
yeah i can sing let me just play this
real quick no but i think once you're on
a little mermaid float all the rules are
all the rules
and that really is the point yeah this
is the point
once you're on there and it's
thanksgiving you can show up naked it's
just like look i don't care at this
point that's right so uh they uh
send you the tape and you just learn it
and you learn exactly what you do so you
haven't
memorized that now why are they still
plugging that movie that movie's like a
couple of years old i don't know what's
going on
i have no idea they just tell me what
float to go when i went up there and did
it
i have no clue why they're plugging in
just which float am i on
because i would think i i actually was
was campaigning you know
this show's been on like a year and a
half now and i thought it was high time
that there was a conan
float in the parade
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look it's actually it's actually
frightening people
they're leaving it's actually scaring
people that's great yeah that's great
would you if i can get that thing i'm
trying very hard i'm getting through the
bureaucracy if i can get that thing
will i be on the phone will you ride on
top in the hair and sing a song
definitely do that man thank you very
much thank you look for it next year
it looks so sad walking out the door it
looks so dejected it's like yeah
gotta make a buck that's the saddest
looking thing i've ever seen
yeah well you're in college now right
i'm in college now in film school at usc
and uh it's it's it's really hard this
is your uh
freshman first first year yes wow so
we're working hard and uh
we had a midterm about three weeks ago
that was literally the hardest test i've
ever taken in my entire life you know
you just never realized because in in
college you don't have teachers that are
batting you over the head
you have somebody standing up there for
two hours saying stuff you know
at a mile a minute you know right and
you get down about one-third of it and
they say all right read 5000 pages
and in seven weeks you have a you know
three-hour test
right that's basically what so you have
to do all these things you have to leave
a lot to be on a float or something yeah
exactly you know i had float things to
do
were you studying on part i saw during
part of the parade you were actually
doing that actually right you're doing
calculus you're right no
kids were waving you're like leave me
alone i'm in big trouble exactly
how's it going you so you have this
midterm so one of your finals your
finals are just finals are coming up
exactly they come up december 16th we
have a paper due before that so that's
what i'm working on now now be honest
have you been doing the reading
all along are you going to wait till
like a week before you know the first
four or five weeks i was like doing it
ever i was doing it absolutely perfect
and then what happened was i got busy
and stuff so now i'm trying to catch up
you know but i mean it's
it's it's really hard and i mean as as
long as you just take good notes
sure and that we have these big study
groups and things where like five or six
of us you know
get get together and we put our minds
together and always make sure you get a
couple of nerds in the study
oh absolutely nerds take good notes i'm
telling you it's isn't that good if
that's good advice
make sure yeah don't get into a study
group with a bunch of jocks
make sure there's one guy with really
thick glasses
now i'm giving you the best advice i can
give you hey nothing
uh no nothing at all don't worry about
it
uh let me ask you something uh you i
would think you're in film school
i would think you would have like a lot
of professors and things giving you
scripts you know they want to get movies
made and things like that yeah you're
very powerful you're the student yet you
have all the power
well you know i i just kind of go in
there and uh just keep quiet and just
kind of do the
work and my presence really isn't uh you
know i don't i don't try to
exaggerate myself in any way i just sit
back and be as
quiet as possible but if you don't get a
good grade get your agent involved
okay right absolutely right i'm just
telling you right it's a good joy
very good perfect i understand you were
just you were you're i know you sing
very seriously you were just in
was it southeast asia we were down there
yeah uh over the um
summer yep promoting the first record
even though it was a man you were there
and you got really good crowds but these
are people that don't see blossom
no this is strictly music and uh you
know there's like millions i mean i mean
i think one-third of the world's
population is in like is in like
southeast asia and they just have
millions of uh people and they're not
used to when when actually people come
there and there's a
concert they'll come just because it's a
concert they don't care who it is or
anything so
you think you know seriously you'll see
who i was there was like 30 000 people
they had no idea
i was like i was like nobody so you're
saying so you're saying that like andy
and i could go there
and become huge singing stars there's no
question about it yes we're gonna go
andy and i are gonna go during our
we have a break in two weeks we're gonna
go and we're gonna bring the big conan
head
and become huge stars in southeast asia
that would be excellent that'd be
excellent so it was it was a blast
and we had a lot of fun but it was i
mean it was just such a ride i mean it
really is it really sounds like a good
time oh yeah
listen i know and congratulations you
did the 100th episode of blossom
and you did blossom is on i just want to
make sure i mentioned this it's on
mondays at 8 30 on nbc for anyone who
doesn't know perfect
it was really nice seeing you again
you